[Music]
you
I know what can I do I pay for the
coffee I pick up the dog and I tell the
cop that I'm with animal control and
undercover I still have the dog a
million dollars heck yeah we got a deal
Carter Carter grant VP of Marketing
Chrysler I yeah have we met
we're about to Sam juvy hi Sam Kim
crayon cream on advertising hello Tim
Crandall and advertising are you Hank
rambling sunset I am yeah you know Sally
Pomerance head of Greater for Palmer
ensign Cline Hank Kremlin what a legend
how was your father he went insane he
lived a madhouse now oh well the next
time you see him you tell him Sally
Pomerance from Chicago said alone he
won't understand that talking to him as
I talking about bunny well then you tell
him what's up doc thank you
that'll mean a lot to him Sally
Pomerance just as lovely as I always
imagined I mean wrong color but just as
lovely yeah he imagines everyone black I
suppose it's because I'm black but I
could be big that good could be Carter
we are on our way out because we already
ate here loo these stains on our ties
receipt
I'm guessing all the agencies in town
because you're hearing pitches for your
new campaign well cram woman love to
throw our hat in the ring on that well
have I seen your work I sure have Delta
Airlines blood wiser I don't know it's
not your father's yours Sally I about
Smiths baby and teen kid furniture Harry
D and the DUI lawyer Frank Franklin
insurance oh I've seen that one three
one three plus I thought oh I'm not
seven Frank Franklin that's uh no that's
uh that's very catchy tune yeah but you
know I'm just not sure that your firm is
what we're looking for right now
gentlemen oh sure because you're
probably going to go with these fine
folks from Chicago because that's where
you make your cars wait a minute I don't
what do they make
our Sam right here in Detroit come on
Carter you make your cars here make your
ads here well it took a lot of balls
coming in here like this
well we're already eating fees on or
write to receive yeah um hey what just
come by tomorrow
eight o'clock a candidate I just can't
have dinner my wife and I can't get oh
no I meant a damn yeah makes way more
sense yeah a little early we'll be there
okay see you in the morning thank you
gentlemen
this is Palmer and MS
[Music]